Apple's Max sales have dropped 40
compared to last year the biggest drop
in 23 years the only question is why
well there are three reasons that I'm
gonna explain in this video and one of
those is admittedly me yes I'm sorry
Apple it's partially my fault so let me
explain why ever since Apple launched
the M2 MacBook gear last summer I've
been calling it a disappointing stop Gap
chip and I received so much hate
especially on Tech Twitter for basically
making a big deal out of nothing well I
was trying to warn everybody that the M2
Chip is a stop gap or basically just an
overclocked version of the M1 and that
people who really want an upgrade should
wait for the M3 instead and essentially
the same thing happened when the M2 Pro
and Max MacBook Pros came out in January
I warned people that the chip hasn't
changed that much and that the M3 family
was gonna be a huge deal so they should
probably wait and based on these
terrible Max sales numbers it looks like
lots of people have been doing just that
way back in June of last year I made
this tweet thread detailing my theory on
the M2 Chip and that is that Apple
basically delayed the real M2 Chip and
gave us a stop Gap based on the a15
which was also a stop Gap chip and I
explained throughout this thread that
three nanometer chips were supposed to
be coming last year but they were
delayed by tsmc and because of that
Apple was forced to make the M2 Chip
still based on the same five nanometer
basically the idea is that tsmc promised
that three nanometer chips would be
ready for the iPhone 14 but then in
August of 2021 they confirmed that the
three anime chips would be delayed
missing the window for the 2022 iPhone
which they did and because of that Apple
was initially planning to have the
entire M2 Chip family based on three
nanometer but because of those delays
they would not be ready in time so they
had to basically come up with a stopgap
chip which was the M2 based on the same
five nanometer and it's essentially just
the M 1.5 chip and the M3 that we're
waiting on later this year was supposed
to be the original M2 and therefore the
M2 Chip that we got was a stop Gap chip
and what ended up happening is that the
whole stop Gap chip thing caught on with
even Mark German from Bloomberg calling
the M2 a stop Gap chip ahead of the
better performing M3 chip and things
like that stick especially from Mark who
is the best apple leaf speaker out there
so I'm sorry Apple I'm partially to
blame not only that but people have been
discussing the reason for the huge Max
sales drop and part of that reason
according to an ex-apple employee is
that covid derailed Apple's plans which
led to the delay of the real M1
successor which is of course the second
reason in this video the M3 chip so
let's jump right into that but first
I've got to talk about the perfect
sidekick to any Mac or MacBook the new
geminos monitor from mobile pixels
featuring ergonomically designed dual
stacked 24-inch monitors with minimal
gap between them and very minimal desk
space required thanks to the built-in
base that has extra ports like USB A and
C ports ethernet and two SD card slots
plus the monitor angles can be quickly
adjusted and pivoted to match your
preference and and height of the
built-in 1080p webcam so check out the
geminos dual stack monitor using the
link below now just about the first time
we heard about Apple's M3 chips was way
back in December of 2021 saying that
Apple would use tsmc's three nanometer
chip technology for the M3 chip and that
they would likely debut in 2023
including iPhone 15 models with the a17
ship and apple silicon Max with M3 chips
and it turns out that rumor from digit
times was actually correct and spot on
and then in April of 2022 mark gurman
from Bloomberg said that Apple's already
working on an iMac with an M3 Chip
saying that they're going to be skipping
the M2 basically because it's a stop cap
with no real major advantage for the
iMac and that that would be coming in
2023 at least so he was correct there as
well and then finally only last month
Mark confirmed that the new iMac with
the M3 chip is an advanced stage of
development coming as soon as later this
year with final confirmation just
yesterday morning saying that yes we did
get a huge Max shipment drop over 40
percent but it should start to turn
around with the upcoming new 13-inch air
15-inch Air Mac Pro and M3 iMac that is
what people are waiting on and then of
course we've had countless leaks and
rumors of the MacBook Air coming with
the new three nanometer M3 chip the
second half of the year and then once
again from nine to five Mac an exclusive
leak that both the 13 and 15 inch will
use M3 chips maybe even a refreshed
MacBook Pro yes coming later this year
so why is the M3 chip such a big deal
well tsmc's three nanometer process is a
major step up because we've been on five
nanometer ever since the original M1
came out in 2020 and yes the M2 and M2
Pro Max ships are five nanometer chips
and even the a16 bionic chip in the
iPhone is called four nanometer but it's
really just third generation five
nanometer so the M3 built-on three
nanometer will be the first major IP
Improvement in years which basically
means that the underlying technology
that the actual CPU and GPU cores are
built on is going to be improved with
three nanometer transistors that are
basically able to produce more
performance at the same level of power
usage or producing the same performance
with less power usage like for example
this leak that came out saying that
Apple's a17 three nanometer chip could
be 35 percent more energy efficient
enabling longer battery life which
everybody loves on iPhones MacBooks
anything portable it's a very big deal
and not only that but I actually did
some M3 chip performance estimations in
this video right here and it is a
massive Improvement so much so that the
M3 chip will likely outperform the Bend
14 inch base MacBook Pro now that by
itself is going to get a lot of people
to upgrade from their original M1 model
to the M3 because of the huge jump in
performance and then of course people
are going to be buying up the M3 iMac
coming as soon as later this year
because the M1 model just wasn't enough
performance for some people who wanted a
desktop Mac and it's already two years
old people are waiting for a better
version to buy and since the M3 chip is
so powerful it's going to be perfect for
people who want a high performance iMac
and then of course we have the 15 inch
MacBook Air which just yesterday we got
another leak saying that the components
are underway they're coming they're
being built Ross young just confirmed it
and it's looking like a WWDC launch is
likely although I do think that it makes
more sense to launch in the fall but
there is a chance that it could come at
WWDC and personally I think that the
15-inch Air Model is going to be a
massive instant hit allowing people to
finally get a better deal on a large
screen Apple silicon Mac so the sales of
the 14-inch MacBook Pro are probably
going to suffer however we're also
expecting the M3 Pro and M3 Max ships
built on three nanometer next year so
people should probably just wait on that
if they want a really high performance
MacBook and then finally the third
reason for the max sales going down is
the macro economy which is going down
due to a chain reaction of events that
started with covid and a massive over
stimulus plan which ended up causing
inflation which began eating away at
people's savings which then caused the
FED to raise interest rates faster than
they've ever have before in an attempt
to lower inflation by lowering the
wealth effect which literally means that
the FED wants people to feel less
wealthy so they spend less money and
that is now causing consumer spending to
go down to incredibly low levels
especially in the tech sector just look
at some of these headlines Samsung is
going to be reducing chip production
because their profits dropped by 96
another headline desktop GPU sales hit a
20 year low Foxconn tsmc Revenue they
all fell the entire Tech sector is going
down and layoffs are up nearly five-fold
so far this year with tech companies
leading the way and then now those
layoffs are showing up in the jobs data
especially in the South finally they're
starting to show up and here you can see
this savings rate has collapsed to just
2.2 percent basically matching the
lowest level ever of Americans saving
money in their bank and why is that
happening well because the inflation
rate has been outgrowing wage growth so
it's harder to make a living right now
and that of course is leading to record
low consumer sentiment about the economy
so when consumers don't feel good about
it they start spending less money and
here we just had a headline saying that
in 2021 renters making less than 30k a
year had just 380 dollars left each
month after paying rent the lowest
amount in more than 20 years and then
this chart right here saying that
household excess savings will likely be
gone by
mid-2023 so if you have no excess
savings who's going to be buying Tech
products like Max right now and all of
that is happening while credit card
balances are skyrocketing to record high
levels that we've never seen before so
no wonder Max sales are going down but I
am hopeful that with the launch of the
M3 chip and those Macs everything is
going to start recovering and a lot of
people are going to start buying
hopefully everything turns out better by
then so there you go hopefully you'll
enjoy this video and if you did let me
know down in the comment section below
click the circle above to subscribe
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
thank you